bene a tutti i ragazzi che sono video
sono fa vj oggi siamo in un nuovo
episodio di in segreto e non può ragazzi
che non facevo il segreto anzi non mi
ricordo l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto
sinceramente però dall'ultima volta che
ho fatto un episodio di segreto sono
usciti un miliardo di segreti nuovi allo
ragazzi per chi non sapesse cos'è in
segreto veramente questo sito che dove
una persona può scrivere una qualsiasi
cosa che gli è successa in modo anonimo
e questa cosa viene pubblicata e viene
fatto sapere a tutti quanti quindi basta
inserire la parola fa vj tra le ricerche
e si trovano tutti i segreti che
contengono la parola fa vj andiamo a
leggere ragazzi la cosa più bella che
sto vedendo e che sono tutte donne ad
aver scritto questa donna di 14 anni
tutte così barca va o bichi credibile se
leggiamo prima maschio perché serviva e
crea assurdo uomo di 25 anni vieni stavo
facendo sesso mentre mi guardavo fa vj
con la mia ragazza
anche io faccio il sesso mentre guardo
fa vj con la mia ragazza cosa donna di
vent'anni sono un'amica di famiglia e ci
incontriamo quasi ogni week weekend
weekend ci con dramma quasi ogni weekend
a ogni volta andiamo in giro siamo
circondati da gente mi vergogno da morir
a bribon non ho mica diventare dollari
14 anni quando guardo favi già i miei
cito tantissime quindi di andare in
bagno se no il bagno il letto donna di
22 anni quando ho visto il video della
canzone di gabry ponte tu sei ho pianto
per una settimana perché fa vj ha
baciato un'alta giulia pennella il
taglio sarà 165 170 no forse una 70
troppo non è poi così alta l uomo di 27
anni ho 27 anni e durante l'orario di
lavoro quando non c'è niente da fare
stavolta anche quando sono occupatissimo
di nascosto guardi video da sapri gamer
di mezzi ed i farisei siete forti anche
io ogni tanto leggo i tuoi commenti
mentre lavoro perché in teoria questo
sarebbe mio lavoro
teoria e va beh adoro fa vj e lo sogno
ogni notte per sentirmi meglio dalla
vita che mi ha dato tante sofferenze
spero che un giorno davanti a me mi
trovassi fa vj spero che un giorno
davanti a te ti trovassi un dizionario
uomo li seri giorni ho ricevuto il duomo
di pasqua di favi j
ho messo la foto su insta è un casino di
mi piace prendi le uova per fare mi
piace c'è donna di vent'anni ho
vent'anni sono ritenuta bella [ __ ] io
sono ritenuto bello figo da molti
ragazzi il mio problema è che non riesco
a fidanzarmi con nessuno perché adoro fa
vj amo lui è servito e voglio trovarmi
il ragazzo così rimarrà singola vita
escono ma è la stessa tipa di che che si
finge la mia amica cioè in realtà non
esiste sta tipa uomo di 17 anni
un giorno ero con la mia ragazza e stava
guardando un video di fa vj e non so per
quale motivo le iniziate a toccarmi il
meno male che mettete vs dischi ragazzo
non potevo monetizzare birre da quel
momento scopriamo ogni giorno grazie
mille fa vi prego so che faresti lo
stesso per me non ho anche mito che c'è
nel senso
vabbè che vi sono gay e mi e ci dà
tantissimo ma vj quando ho visto video
musicali che compare mi sono eccitato
tantissimo stanotte ho sognato di farlo
confavi genere ho capito però no basta
dai ragazzi questa bellissima donna di
21 anni ho iniziato quasi per scherzo a
guardare i video di fa vj e mezzo
youtube e in poco tempo ne sono
diventata totalmente dipendente il
problema è che ora mentre li guardo non
riesco a non pensare all'idea di un
ipotetica org
grazie dell'asterisco un ipotetica
giorgio argia che farei molto volentieri
con tutti loro
ok ok va bene uomo di 21 anni sono in
bici sono un vicino del vicino del
famoso scazzosi ne sono un vicino del
vicino e casa è un vicino cech show sono
un vicino del vicino del famoso fra
amici
mi diverto troppo a sentirlo imprecare
quando fa vj registrando i video lo
tiene sveglio con suo gridare per questo
invito i miei amici all'una di notte per
sentire il vicino di favi jazz lui
invita gli amici per sentire il mio
vicino che si lamenta che urla donna di
21 anni quanto vorrei che lorenzo ostuni
fa vijecnica gas e ogni tanto ti ho
cagata zia dollari 17 anni un giorno
sognai che mia madre che mia madre per
regalo aveva convinto fa vj a portarmi
in giro per il mio compleanno
ci avrei pure creduto in quel sogno se
non fosse per il fatto che loro e
guidava andata bene che era un sogno zia
anche se guidavo io e tu stavi dietro
agli nella merda uomo di 14 anni io odio
fa vj per me non ha niente da fare e
fallo stupido in realtà però ha ragione
non è che sia proprio finta starò non
votatelo male la giovane regata donna di
31 anni ho perso letteralmente la testa
per fa vj guardo i sei vita ogni ora
della giornata soffermandomi spesso
sulle espressioni del suo viso sui gesti
delle mani ma non mi si vedono le mani
divide e sulla dolcezza che emana
no questo è tanfo zia a doghe dolcezza
ed è l'unico che riesce a strapparmi in
sorriso nelle giornate distorte amicizie
sono stato attenzionato da una mills è
comunque ieri pomeriggio stava in
salotto a guardare i video di favi j
ad un tratto entra mia nonna mentre
famiglia indice 4 solchi quanto soci
mamma mia e mia nonna pensa che io
stesso in videochiamata un qualche mio
amico ho provato a spiegarle ma nulla è
convinta che io sia una mangiata mi
dispiace zia non volevo che peraltro
appena ripetuto in questo video chissà
quante e quanti ragazzi c'era la nonna
in camera nonne che siete entrati in
camera adesso che avete sentito che ho
detto quanto lo su chi non sto parlando
di vostra nipote
sto parlando della mamma degli haters se
sei un ente che stai guardando questo
video non dell'ater sto parlando di sua
figlia ho sognato di essere fidanzata
con lorenzo ostuni fa vj direi che sono
piuttosto grande preferenza ogni del
genere
ma neanche dando zia ho visto prima di
peggio soprattutto non sono ossessionato
da lui come la maggior parte delle sue
fan ma ammetto che nel sogno mi faceva
parecchio citate a quando vuoi
invidio da morire la mia cuginetta di 16
anni perché ha incontrato fa vj al
centro commerciale
a vent'anni la cuginetta di 16 anni ma
grazie alla cuginetta cioè non è che tu
a vent'anni sana vecchia decrepita io a
21 nel caso su una quercia secolare
durante un ciocchetti durante il periodo
mestruale garden di parigi mi rilassano
e alleviare i dolori di pancia scusa
quando guardo il grande famiglia i mie
cito un casino che quando vado a scuola
gli lancio le penne alla prof e lei mi
sospende che cosa stracazzo appena
eletto donna di 25 anni mimas e sculazzo
pensando alla vigente
grazie a dei ragazzi ci siamo contro
l'ultima di oggi perché va bene ormai
degenerato tutto sono due settimane
ormai che la mia ragazza mi ha mollato
perché ha detto di non avermi più e che
s'è innamorata di quel di famiglia il
mio segreto è da una settimana che
riguarda ogni giorno cinque o sei video
di fa vj e mi esercito a parlare
atteggiarmi come lui così fra poco il
ritornello dalla mia ragazza e la
riconquisterà aspettami non ti lascerò
andare caro caro amico mio uomo uomo di
17 anni il segreto non è saper parlare o
gesticolare come il segreto sta nella
grandezza del pene e quella non la puoi
cambiare idea a la botta nella mano sul
muro il carbone va bene ragazzi direi
che possono chiudere qui oggi con il
segreto visto una sfilza di roba che era
meglio non vedere però ormai vabbè
quindi i ragazzi facciamo un appello
enorme a tutti quelli che stanno
guardando questo video e se vi è
successo un qualcosa di strano con me
l'eccesso di me scrive the los il
segreto che prima da fare
la ricerca però devono essere cose bene
fatemi sapere ragazzi scrivete però io
farò poi una seconda reaction così a
tutta sta roba perché fantastico quindi
ragazzini spero che vi sia piaciuto come
se non mi piace anche vari social che
con descrizione mi raccomando mentre
fate il sesso
no non mi non guardate i miei video no
nella ragazzi
[Musica]